Speaker 1: Today.
We had a horrible thing happen.
It happens every once in a while.
We have a guest scheduled, a beautiful guest
and they no call, no show, giving us no notice
whatsoever that they are not planning to join
the interview.
But the upside is we'll hear from a few of
you via discord at David Pakman dot com slash
discord.
Let's go first to Rose from the United States.
Rose, it's the United States is so general,
but welcome.
Speaker 3: Hello?
Can you hear me?
Speaker 1: Yes, I can.
Speaker 4: Oh, the audio quality is fine.
I know you're quite a stickler for it.
Speaker 1: It's.
It's quite good.
Thank you.
Speaker 4: Okay.
Yeah, well, I really feel uncomfortable disclosing
my location on the Internet.
That being said, my question is, there's a
really big gap between scientists and the
general public, and it feels like the gap
keeps growing and it gets more and more difficult
to convey to the general public the precise
nature of science and the difficulties associated
with it.
And it feels like scientists are failing as
a political entity to talk to the general
public.
How do you feel about this?
Speaker 1: I agree with you.
I mean, I think here's the thing.
If you told me I'm not a scientist, but I
my instinct is if you told scientists you
are failing as a political entity, they would
say we're not a political entity.
And I but at the same time, I acknowledge
what you're saying, which is we I mean, maybe
it's science education that's failing and
critical thinking and epistemology.
I don't I don't know.
But you're absolutely right.
In your in your observation about the effects
of it.
Speaker 4: What can we do?
Because I have I spent so much time thinking
about this because in light of global warming.
It's way worse than what most reports suggest.
The most people don't know this, but the IPCC
is meant to be a sort of a politically favorable
take on that.
It doesn't take into account multiple feedback
loops, including the tying of the permafrost
in the Arctic.
It doesn't take into account ocean salinity,
which changes the CO2 dissolved in the oceans
exactly like multiple feedback loops going
on.
All of which suggest that the reality of climate
change is going to be way worse than what
most people expect.
Hmm.
Speaker 1: The situation is more dire.
In other words.
Speaker 4: Yes.
Yes.
The IPCC reports are the best case scenario,
the best possible hypothetical scenario.
And it's and yet so many scientists I know
personally and I've talked to them about this,
they are they struggle to get people to understand
this.
And they're worried that if they actually
talk about what's going to happen with real
precision and actual facts, that they'll be
dismissed as apocalyptic loons.
Right.
Speaker 1: So and they probably go they're
probably correct to think that that's what
would happen.
Yeah.
I don't know how to bridge the gap, Rose.
I mean, this is this is an ongoing conversation
where it almost feels too late for so many
people.
And there's also the political machine that
that wants to stay on fossil fuels that we're
up against.
And we need to start teaching critical thinking
and media literacy very early.
I actually have a bunch of books waiting to
be read on a pilot that deal directly with
this issue.
And so I'm hoping in a few months maybe I'll
have some greater insights into it, but you're
at least identifying the problem correctly.
Speaker 4: Could you share the booklist?
I'd love to read it.
Speaker 1: I will once I've read the books
because I always want to read books before
I recommend them.
But absolutely.
Speaker 4: Okay.
It was great talking to you today.
Speaker 1: Rose, thank you so much.
Speaker 4: Absolutely.
Thank you.
Thanks, David.
Speaker 1: All right.
There is a rose with a very dystopian but
necessary.
Commentary.